Hey Youtubers, It's Charlie!
Thank You everyone that submitted questions for my Doctor Who Q&A
Generally, a lot of questions about what's going on with Clara as well as what's going to be going on in the Christmas Special
Question 1 - jilly G asks, if The Master had
been saving people’s minds since humans
first developed concepts of the afterlife,
why didn’t Clara and The Doctor already
know about 3W? And Do you think they’ll
bring Clara back for the Christmas Special?
Since almost everyone is asking about Clara
I’ll talk about that first. Yes, I do think
she’ll appear but I don’t think she’ll
be part of what we saw in the trailer.
I think The Doctor will have the ice station
monster storyline and Clara will appear separately.
There are so many things they still have to
address like Orson Pink. There has to be a
Danny Pink child in order for their to be
Orson Pink, his grandson to exist.
It’s possible we could see a super preggo
Clara. If the show moves in real time it would
be less than 9 months. Strax kept going on
and on about fluid retention in the premiere,
and throwing the idea of having children in
Clara’s face all season. It just feels like
Clara being pregnant would be the most logical
way to wrap those things up.
As for 3W, you could say that the organization
was incredibly secretive about reaching out
to the families of the recently deceased.
We didn’t get a scene with Doctor Chang
meeting with normal people. So we have no
idea how those interactions played out.
If they just auto-saved people and didn’t
tell the families.
The whole 3W thing could have been completely
in Doctor Chang’s head. Like The Master
fooling him into thinking it was a public
company that did all the things he explained
in his office with Clara.
Like the company was a fiction in his head,
no one in the real world knew about it. He
just thought they did because The Master was
messing with his head.
The less likely explanation is that all The
Master’s changes to the timeline hadn’t
caught up with Clara and The Doctor yet.
It feels like characters are able to fool
The Doctor whenever the story requires big
reveals like this. Or something distracts
the Doctor from seeing the very obvious Cyberman
eyes everywhere.
Question 2 - Killer Cookie asks, I don’t
understand why Missy didn’t Regenerate?
I don’t think we’ll get an official explanation
till the next time we see Missy. I would be
amazed if she showed up in the Christmas Special.
The best theories I’ve seen are that Cyber
Brig’s gun transported her somewhere else
and the Doctor transported her somewhere else
with her Compact the instant before the Brig’s
gun hit her.
She’s dematerializing as if she’s not
exploding. A normal cyber blaster would probably
just have stunned her or caused her to regenerate.
The other possibility is that wasn’t the
real Missy on the ground. So that’s why
she didn’t regenerate.
I kind of like the life model decoy explanation,
the Doctor is a liar, but I do think he was
ready to kill her. And he was extremely surprised
when the Brig got her first. The salute moment
felt so sacred that I don’t think Moffat
would take that back by saying the Brig’s
gun transported missy somewhere else.
If you have an alternate theory just write
it in the comments.
Question 3 - Salem asks, did you notice Clara’s
Eyes in the Opening Sequence?
I think that was them paying off all the Doctor
Oswald moments in series 8. They’d spent
multiple scenes with her either pretending
to be The Doctor or doing things that only
The Doctor does.
It could be part of something bigger but until
we get more information or Moffat explains
it in an interview I’m going to think of
it as just a one-off thing, just something
fun.
Question 4 - Brilchan asks, do you think The
Brig is totally blown up or flying around
in space now?
That would be awesome if they did a spinoff
story about the adventures of the Cyber Brig.
I think tumblr can help you there, but in
the official canon I think he’s gone in
a cloud of cyber parts.
Question 5 - Mitchell asks, do you think Missy
Gave the Doctor the correct coordinates for
Gallifrey and he was just forgetting it was
in another dimension?
Yes, and also a number of other people in
the comments pointed out that the actual coordinates
are the same coordinates that The Fourth Doctor
gives up during Pyramids of Mars.
So when Missy says it’s where it’s always
been. She’s really being honest.
Number 6 - Drew asks, what do you think Nick
Frost meant during the Christmas trailer when
he said, “It can’t end like that”?
I think he’ll force the Doctor to come clean
to Clara and they’ll drop the lies they
told in a way that will give her run some
closure.
Santa will give them the gift of closure.
Which is all a fan could ever ask for.
Number 7 - Chaz asks, what do you think about
the controversy over people being upset after
the last episode?
The Don’t Cremate me thing. I usually ignore
stuff like that. I think it was mostly localized
to the UK. In America stuff like that happens
all the time. Anytime something crazy happens
on tv or in a movie or a book a small group
of people will always flip their shit and
scream at broadcasters.
Anytime I hear people getting upset like that
I just picture the mob from South Park. Where
they all say rabble rabble.
Number 8 - Danny asks, who’s your favorite
Doctor?
Right now it’s still Matt Smith followed
closely by David Tennant. I still feel like
it’s too early to put Capaldi into context
with the other Doctor’s. Give him Series
9 and then I think there will be a better
basis for comparison.
I always try to keep an open mind about new
actors, especially the secondary actors and
the companions.
None of them are super sacred to me, I really
enjoy all of them. But I usually watch Doctor
Who hoping to feel happy. And both Smith and
Tennant made me pretty happy. As opposed to
depressed or freaked out.
Number 9 - Dark Neko Studio asks, how possible
is it for Santa Nick Frost to be an exiled
Time Lord?
Number 10 - Ultimate gamings asks, is Michelle
Gomez Scottish or English?
There were a couple that asked about Missy’s
Scottish Accent. Just to answer your question
first. Michelle Gomez was born in Glasgow
just like Peter Capaldi. So I think part of
the reason Missy speaks with a Scottish accent
is because it comes so naturally and on the
set they thought it worked.
In the context of the Character, I think The
Master would choose a Scottish accent is because
she’s obsessed with
The Doctor.
Based on the first time we see her I think
that The Master regenerated into Missy long
before the 11th Doctor regenerated into Scottish
12.
So it’s a little bit real life influence
and a little bit obsessive Master.
Winner - Raggedy Girl